hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
this is the follow-up on the last video
of a new battery revolution in that
video you'd recall that there's plenty
of battery research going on at various
stages of implementation and that new
uses for batteries were coming online
it's highly recommended that you watch
that video first in this video we'll
take a look at the worst case scenario
for our environment that is we stick to
lithium iron over the next few decades
rather than liquid aluminium or anything
else mentioned in the last video if this
worst-case scenario happens what's in
store for battery recycling for this
video I teamed up with the Faraday
institution particularly rub Somerville
he helped me answer some questions we'll
hear from him a little bit later it's
clear that a battery revolution is
coming but how long do we have until we
have to start worrying about
environmental factors from when a new
wave of electric cars and battery
systems start expiring Rob told me that
there are ready some issues in the
battery recycling of electric cars
involved in accidents but in terms of a
global environmental issue
Tesla batteries degrade about 9% after
traveling 270,000 kilometers or 168
thousand miles a Model X has been
clocked at over 600,000 kilometers so in
truth no one really knows how long these
cars will last but some estimates put it
at about 17 years like I mentioned in
the previous video there are secondhand
users after electric cars these involve
things like household power commercial
infrastructure and gradually less
demanding uses until the batteries can
only power something like a TV remote
reliably but beyond that it's reached
the end of its life and it's time for
recycling so let's be conservative and
say that we have about 20 years all up
so the problem the waste materials of
batteries can be toxic we have metal
oxides phosphates as well as aluminium
copper graphite and organic electrolytes
but there's also harmful lithium salts
and various plastics if we don't take
care of recycling these components there
could be major environmental
consequences today the problem is that
95 percent of lithium-ion batteries are
either stockpiled or end up in landfill
which can cause explosions or prolong
tavar
damaged as a lot of people are aware
with this Samsung Galaxy Note seven
lithium-ion batteries can be a bit
dangerous so this is called thermal
runaway thermal runaway is when a living
wild self self heats and at least the
cell getting damaged
this can cause degassing which is when
hot gases are released from the cell it
can lead to fire when these gases catch
fire or a clean - explosion if these
gases can't get out they build up and
they the cell just explodes crushing who
appears in the cell will create an
internal short circuit which will create
a rapid uncontrolled discharge which
will cause it to heat up which will
cause thermal run-on so this is one of
the great challenges in lithium-ion
battery recycling you need to do it
safely
because setting fire to all the things
you try to recycle is not a very
efficient way of recycling
[Music]
the main culprit is phones and laptops
right now when we throw them in the
garbage it's way too expensive to sort
them from the rest of the trash there
needs to be education on this issue and
it's starting
for example the Victorian government in
Australia is launching an awareness
campaign to educate people on the
dangers the good news is that with
electric cars and utility storage this
is much less of an issue the recycler
knows that they're dealing solely with
batteries and can recycle accordingly
but there still remains a problem of
battery labeling a lot of lithium-ion
batteries they don't the packaging does
not describe what is inside the cell
this makes it significantly harder for
people looking at the recycling but
specifying roughly what's in there for
example how badly it could go wrong if
we put it through a shredder so that we
can take the necessary safety
precautions
well meth attempting to recycle them so
having that sort of information
available to recyclers would be very
important now with all of that in mind
let's take a quick look at the latest
research most of this is centered around
my talk with Rob and a September 2018
study here's a flowchart of how a
typical lithium-ion recycling process
goes currently in research general
improvements have been made both in the
pretreatment and hydrometallurgical
processes that's the black and red
dotted boxes
[Music]
hydron perigee it's one of the newer
processes as being looked at more cells
are broken open in a shadow or a crusher
you then separate the components you can
separate the volatile electrolyte you
can separate plastics and then the
important part which is the black mass
which is the electrode coating you can
then dissolve the black mass in acid and
then separate out the different metals
using solvent extraction to get pure
sorts of different metals that were in
cells in the late 2018 study ultrasonic
washing that is using low frequency
sound to agitate fluids have been proven
to use less energy than crushing or
heating separate parts in the study
there have been many chemical components
separation methods that you recovery
above 90 percent of important raw
materials but one such process stood out
to me it was an environmentally friendly
bio leaching process that recovered a
hundred percent copper hundred percent
lithium and 75 percent of the atom in
you this method used hydrochloric acids
as well as surprising acids such as
citric acid found in fruits surprisingly
even certain types of fungi found in
decaying vegetation in soil can you
bacteria that remove and separate cobalt
from lithium there is a subset of hydro
pathology called bio hydro mythology
which is where bacteria are used to do a
lot of the legwork by the bacteria
producing high particles which are
suitable for reuse in a Cell
the bacteria poop the metals and it's
really cooled really fine particles of
mixed metal oxide which is what we're
looking for in cells on the plus side
it's got really low running costs
because you just just need the bacteria
to it and they do that thing and it can
work on impure feeds however the
disadvantage is that it's really quite
slow so when the raw materials are
recovered what do we do with them some
elements can be used in concrete magnets
and even new batteries the study
concludes that we should aim to have
recycling with late energy consumption
but also recovers all important elements
but with zero environmental pollution
there's research that exists that
achieves this but they're only in the
beginning stages the study also
concludes that there needs to be a
standard diet recycling process
batteries that are designed with
recycling in mind are essential
robberies also designing cells for
disassembly currently it is a nightmare
but I take them apart I just took one
apart my glove box day before yesterday
and its reason it's really really fiddly
trying to take it apart because that is
not currently the sort of thing that
anyone has really care about so far
they're just designed to get the energy
density and cell life that's all they
really care about making it light making
it small that's that's really view being
the only target so far if you can make
also make it easy to recycle that would
really improve things the ultimate goal
is to have the same statistics as the
recycling process of lead acid batteries
currently 99% of all lead acid batteries
are recycled this is because lead acid
batteries are a much older technology
that stretches back to 1859 but lithium
ion on the other hand has only been in
widespread use since the early 1990s
companies like lifecycle are close to
total recovery and can produce chemicals
good enough for a satisfactory
performance in a second-generation
recycled battery the system is a closed
loop and the goal is to process up to
250,000 tons of lithium-ion batteries
per year enviros stream an Australian
company has recycled 240,000 kilograms
of batteries in 2018 so what about Tesla
what are they doing with Tesla freezers
there Panasonic batteries with liquid
nitrogen to prevent further chemical
reactions from there they're shredded
and crushed into tiny pieces separating
the valuable components the long-term
goal for Tesla is to reuse recycled
materials from used batteries at the
gigafactory itself cutting the need for
mining and shipping new components
they're also trying to make it easier to
replace battery packs a point which Rob
pointed out is critical for the future
currently when you recycle a car you
take out things like the engine oil
brake fluid unused petrol that is
currently required by law what I would
like to happen is for it to be required
by law for batteries to be easily enough
accessible but this can be done at the
same time as taking out these fluids
rather than digging through from the top
just being able to drop the bottom or
something like that a company called GME
core has a fully closed loop recycling
system where they can save at least 70
percent of co2 emissions from the
recycling process the byproducts such as
refined metals like cobalt and nickel
can be used to harden tools or used in
grease like wd-40 and even resold to
battery manufacturers to highlight this
yummy core is one of the largest
suppliers of lithium cobalt oxide to the
battery manufacturers Yumiko
demonstrates that recycling can be
economically viable Tesla has worked
with umicar and found a way to recycle
battery packs profitably without
unsustainable government initiatives it
should be noted that due to only a
handful of cars coming back at this
early stage and electric vehicle life
cycles tesla hasn't had the ability to
reuse and recycle the parts at high
volume
so governments around the world are
looking at different things to
incentivize recycling Australia for
example has put a band on sending
batteries to waste and landfill the law
takes effect on the first of July 2019
in January 2019 the United States
government established the battery
recycling R&D center as well as prizes
totaling 5.5 million dollars for
entrepreneurs to find innovative
solutions to collecting storing and
transporting discarded lithium-ion
batteries for adventure recycling Rob
also mentioned some work going on
Switzerland in countries up to
Switzerland they have a tax on the sale
of batteries which then goes to the
battery recyclers this means that you
can recycle batteries at any shop in the
country and they will be collected and
sent to central facilities separated for
recycling so what about lithium mining
as it turns out all mining is bad for
the environment but as far as mining
goes lithium isn't that harmful if done
responsibly it's more sustainable than
coal which is 100 percent consumed and
non-renewable lithium can be and is
often produced by extracting natural
lithium salt out of the ground and
letting excess water evaporate the
environment to impact on with this
method is minimal if done correctly this
doesn't mean that there aren't risks if
the process is negligent then damage may
be done to the water supply of
surrounding areas although it's in its
early days companies are already
efficiently recycling used batteries and
new research is showing that it's
possible to achieve this biologically
with almost a zero carbon footprint the
Faraday institution are also working
hard on solutions
I'll let Rob detail what they're working
on at the moment the parent institution
has various different projects there are
four five start projects these include
the battery recycling project which is
what we're looking at battery
degradation which is modeling how
batteries degrade over time and over use
multi scale modeling project which is
attempting to predict battery
performance and then a project on next
generation of solid state batteries
these are the four projects that the
parent institution has at the moment the
battery recycling project which is the
one that I'm involved in is split
between seven universities the
University of Birmingham Newcastle
Leicester Edinburgh
oxford brookes & cardiff & liverpool the
University of Newcastle is looking at
assessing the state of health of
lithium-ion cells and modules within the
pack and determining basically how
healthy they are can they put back into
into the battery pack and reused in the
car or should they go on to Second Life
applications and if so which second life
application should that be around all of
this there is the business and
regulation aspect which is looking at
the life cycle assessments the
environmental impact the economics and
the legal and policy impacts of this
sort of thing
[Music]
but with all of that being said we still
have quite a few years to get this
perfect it'll be a while since the
battery boom leads to a massive glass of
batteries that need to be recycled and
this is also the worst case scenario if
graphene silicon liquid and aluminium
based batteries don't take off within
that time period one conclusion there's
still plenty of work to do and fuchsia
battery manufacturers have to design
with recycling in mind so let me know
what you think in the comments section
below thanks for watching this has been
- go go you've been watching cold fusion
if you've just stumbled across this
channel feel free to subscribe and I'll
see you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a go
[Music]
you